for people who are watching this who
might have the same
situation like you have a speech
impediment and you
have never let that be an excuse for you
to do what you want to do right
and you're also um you know
some people are shamed by that or they
do their best to hide it but i think
that it's
important for there's somebody who could
be watching this right now who's going
through the same situation
and might want to be a rapper or might
want to think
you might want to do tv or whatever it
might not think that they can
you know what i'm saying like and that's
why you don't like when i first let it
out
and i mean you know on the suede show
you know you know that i have a
stuttering problem i actually went up
there not trying to hide it
and stuff like that right now i've been
studying a little bit on this
they're pretty much gonna see it but
i've been working on it you know i mean
so
i'm not as bad but my student is real
bad you know what i'm saying so
i just stopped hiding it because i
wanted people to know
all right i mean you know this is my
imperfection perfection
mm-hmm you know i'm not perfect i want
them
uh you know because i know it's a lot of
people that's that's probably
are capable of doing so many things but
they'd be nervous on how somebody's
going to look at them
yeah that'd be the whole thing of when
you stutter and you catch a real bad
stuttering and then you wondering
if they're looking at you like you're
crazy right right
yeah with me being in the position that
i
am this is this is what let them know
that
no you have a stuttering problem but
you're not [ __ ] you're trying to say
you're not slow
i'm very intelligent well you've also
got had an extremely
successful you know career using
your voice and and and i think that
that's
got to be inspirational because that
would be the single most insecure thing
that anybody could probably do
and that's decide to be an artist a
musician you know sing a rapper when i
first started doing
interviews like that i really stopped
doing interviews because of my
stuttering
and then i said nah you know what that's
not a way where i could really show them
that it can actually be done with a
stuttering problem
i mean you know i was born with this i
got it on both sides of my family
you know my father's stutter when my
father said i saw my father yeah
my mom's uh my grandfather's stuff badly
he found child said was he just
um let me which he just passed away but
uh
he had a real bastard of a problem to
the point where you came and called him
on the phone
you know i'm saying so you know i
actually got it on both sides of my
family you know i mean so
i just be wanting people to understand
and know
that it could still be done even even
with it you found john cena right now i
can barely speed it but
i'll flame knight will send these
rappers